my all-time favorite shepherd's pie
what's the secret
behind a really good
shepherd's pie
i would think the vegetables you use and
growing in it
so we're going to use leeks
and onions and they'll start browning
off the mints you know no color no
flavor i've never forgotten that you
know that yep
so
good to have color gotta have color
otherwise it puts that grey tinge on the
shepherd's pie that looks sick greasy
and cheap and nasty
they don't want that do we and i know
you don't do cheaper nasty let me clear
your peelings now
all right thank you very much there's no
nails in there now is that no
don't be chicken
i remember
your
amazing shepherd's pie
and that lovely little restaurant used
to work in in sheep street in stratford
so you never got food sent back
no sometimes they complained that there
were
you never ever got a complaint no
how long do you work at that restaurant
for
six shoes six years
oh hello chilly
what are you cooking i'm gonna make okay
i sort of modern version of nanny's
shepherd's pie dad shouldn't manny be
doing the cooking because she's the
better cook excuse me right mum would
you would you chop our onion please
daddy yeah oh gosh your eyes are gonna
water
daddy what's in this spot sorry
in there we got a delicious steamed
treacle and date pudding let's just
separate it for you
um how do skeletons call their friends
how do skeletons call their friend i'm
not too sure on the scalabone i'm just
gonna tilly come on
okay so two cats are in a race one is
called one two three and the other is
called
under 12. who won
the depends who's the fastest cat one
two three because under 12 cats sank
[Music]
oh goodness
tells why do you make a nice cup of tea
for honey you want me to disappear
thank you
bye so give that a little fry off okay
nice
quarter these jokes they get worse oh
she's certainly having a bit of fun
sauce worcester sauce that's gonna give
that really nice spicy seasoning
oh thank you
okay
tomato puree in
you could put a ton of tomatoes in this
if you want you could yeah
put that mince back in there once it's
drained
i'm just going to put a little touch
i know you'll go crazy at this a little
touch of red wine
really
why the red wine well because i'm going
to make it nice and rich
okay
reduce the red wine down yeah and then
start covering your
with your stock
now i'm gonna bring it up to the bowl
okay and then get some fresh rosemary
okay
like little taste yes please
does it hot
it's a little bit hot be careful
as it cooks out the wine and the alcohol
will disappear it will be delicious
trust me
now good spring onions we'll chop up
yeah and that's going to go through
the mashed potatoes it's going to sit on
top of that nice nicer i like that
savory yeah delicious mince that's laced
with all that red wine nice so sprinkles
into there please mum
and i'm gonna drain off the potatoes hi
there hello hello
oh hi jack hi hi hello hello jack have a
nice day school yeah oh yeah yeah
so we'll dry out those potatoes and then
mash them no oh can i mash them would
you um holly slice a little knob of
butter in there for jack please
so what was the restaurant you worked
out there were you a chef
cook
i love the diplomacy were you a chef i
was a cookie exactly that
not really
you used to help me with these little
right you kids do
no potatoes
these are nice and fluffy aren't they
aren't they and do you want mum look
delicious mashed potatoes yeah with no
lumps in there
hey weren't you getting it
huh
it's great having you back in the
kitchen mommy now yeah seriously brings
back good memories
no
just
why'd you do that dad i just want to
fork it to get it nice and spiky
so i want that nice crispy topping
and then lightly grate that cheddar
cheese on top and that goes in the oven
literally 20 minutes 180 minutes jack
can you on the door people
that looks lovely doesn't it
even though you said you didn't like it
earlier okay
back in the day mama's meals all came
with two veg and this is no different
but with a modern twist
braised peas and carrots with a
fantastic homemade mint butter
shepherd's pie
glazed on top that looks lovely doesn't
it
and then the carrots
that's why i didn't put carrots in let's
put them on the side i'll see this is my
ultimate childhood dinner shepherd's pie
with crispy cheese champ topping sweet
buttery peas and carrots
now we're gonna make a delicious
beetroot risotto we need to get the
shallots
just slice them in half and then just
chop them like that okay okay now have
you ever made a risotto
no i haven't actually shallots please
into the pan for daddy
add a sprinkle of salt and pepper along
with a couple of crushed cloves of
garlic
once you start cooking the risotto it's
really important
to have your stock
gently boiling away
if we're adding cold stock on top of the
rice all the time it just slows down the
process
generally you cook a nice wide flat pan
if you cook in a deep pan all the rice
sort of cooks at different temperatures
what stock is that in there dad because
that's a vegetable stock
yeah because you can't have different
stocks if it's more vegetarian can you
have chicken stock i made that mistake
once putting beef stock in the
vegetarian soup
did you no i didn't matilda are you sure
i'm positive i'm joking
fry off time how nice does that smell it
smells
delicious rice in that's a bit of a
different rice this is elboria rice it's
a perfect rice for risotto
now it's really important to sear
the rice if we were just to put the
stocking without sweating off the rice
it goes all starchy so keep on stirring
for daddy
it's just gonna make a fun day no flambe
on the risotto
to go with our deep red beetroot theme
i'm adding red wine
followed by the first ladle of stock to
get things started now we're off
wow it's giving it a cloudy sort of look
what's happening to the stock the stock
is reducing down and the rice is sucking
it in that's right so the rice is
actually getting nice and plump
one of risotto is live when it's like
this now we can't stop cooking there we
have to kill it all the way okay ready
for the next ladle i'm ready good girl
here we go ladle in
so we have to make this for literally 20
25 minutes and we're nursing it all the
way
beetroots
peel them rub them a little bit of salt
and sugar yeah and a little bit of aged
balsamic vinegar in there roasted them
i'm gonna grate
my parmesan
how's that rice doing the rice is doing
good
now that is exactly where we want to be
now look look at that nice glossy
textured rice
so beetroot i want you to put two thirds
of the beetroot in there for me saving
one third for the top
good sprinkle the parmesan in there for
me please all over
nice it's like it's snowing again and
then we're just gonna get some nice
butter in there
the butter gives the risotto a really
nice gloss
look at that beautiful
let that come down let it come down
first
all right get your spoon in there now
for daddy
beautifully there you go good
wonderful shake it risotto should be
like lava
it just
flows out and then the rest of the
beetroot on top
and then
finish
and some extra virgin olive oil
on top
i'll pick up the bruschetta you take
that to the table
okay
let's go danny
this is my ultimate vegetarian dinner an
anxious roasted beetroot and thyme
risotto